what's up guys I'm sat here with Adam
Brock who just won the 2022 eviction and
won 20 000 pounds cash and in this
episode I'm going to be catching it with
him finding what he's finding out what
he's doing now what deals he's recently
doing and uh also just to see how your
experience was on the eviction and
what's going on now
uh it's the Whirlwind yeah it's been
amazing so what's going on now I've got
three essays now and a brr that's going
through currently beautiful last time
you were sat on that chair was literally
during the final episode of the eviction
I know it's a bit surreal being back
here yeah so did you expect when you're
into the eviction did you expect the
process to be as it was no I've done a
few challenging things in my life but
that was up there with one of the most
challenging things I've ever done it
really was well I look forward to
finding out exactly what happened from
your experience why don't you start just
pretending to the process because a lot
of people wonder how candidates are
entered into the eviction what the whole
process is me and you now are close we
chat back and forth a lot you're part of
the Inner Circle you're 20 grand up from
The Challenge but the 20 grand is small
money realistically it's kind of there
has to be a prize that makes people
excited but really it's the experience I
think isn't it it's massively
experienced and it's that whole you know
give amount of fish or give them a
fishing rod you know and What I've Done
by joining the academy is you've given
me the fishing rod all right the 20 gram
was a lovely fish I'm not gonna lie but
um the the training that I went through
at the beginning and to be able to even
go into the eviction because had I not
done some of those training courses
before I mean it would have been really
really tough so so why don't you talk to
me about how you got into property what
your background is and how you got into
property in the first place
I must have been
36 and I hadn't I hadn't owned a
property I rented my whole life my
biggest ambition was I've got to get on
the ladder somehow they call it the
ladder but I had to get on there I was
like I'm not gonna
I'm not going to made it ever at least
buy a property
so I bought a first property I was about
37.
and and I started I actually started
renting out as a service accommodation
so I was like wow okay this is this has
got a good gig because I've spent a lot
of money and time building it
um and then I was like I've done this
once but this pays me every single month
and I'm thinking if I have a few more of
these right surely though that'd be
pretty good but I didn't know how I was
just like just flapping around in the
Wind
so I got one of your books uh given to
me
um read that and that was a big game
changer your book and Robert okay thanks
bro
um they were the two big ones and I was
like okay I gotta get into this then I
got the the one pound course thing I was
like okay let's go let's go I went to
Heathrow first that was really really
good and um and then I went to another
one so I went to Heathrow with my wife
and then I went to another one but that
was in the Hard Rock Hotel in London and
it was just really by B I was like okay
you could tell us a lot of money's
London and he's thinking else there's a
lot of money around here and it just
felt really good like being there and I
was thinking right I can I can Elevate
from here and the stuff that you
everything that you were saying I was
like yeah it makes sense yeah it makes
and once you've you can't unsee or and
hear the things that you teach so okay
I'll go get more of this so then I was I
signed up to the uh I think the first
course I did was
essay course because that was like what
I was mainly interested in at the time
yeah so I paid for that one
um and then once I got there I was just
hook line the Sinker then straight on
the academy
um and I haven't looked back really
haven't mate you you changed it you
changed my life to be honest um you
changed even though I mean I've still
got my tile in business but you've even
changed my Approach To That you know um
my wife's seen it as well it's like I
used to just work in my business in my
business all the time now I'm working on
my business and I've got people that
work for me now and I can pursue my
property and I'm still you know got that
going on in the background as well but
it's just you changed my mindset yeah
that's brilliant mate and I think as
well like when you learn the skills in
property like how to systemize a
property business as you say you can
then apply that to other parts of
business other parts of your life which
you've done really well yeah yeah
absolutely and I mean that's why for me
the property is just like it's earning
me money in the background so I'm like
well why can't I just pursue I've got
people that work for me now you know
they rely on on me to throw away so I'm
happy to keep going with that I don't
know how long I'll go with it but for
now it works for me
um but yeah the property it's just so
passive yeah I remember one of the
theaters that you had when we first met
was you said that your your business
you're on the floor a lot Thailand
you're worried that you're you know your
back was get get going yeah
is my back my back is technically a bit
Yeah a bit buggered but um my knees as
well everything you know is just it's
hurting and I'm thinking right I'm 37.
we're gonna be like when I'm 47 57 67.
you know I don't want to be tired until
I drop you know um and also the other
aspect is when you're a Tradesman a lot
of time you don't tend to invest in a
pension so it's just property again is
very much you know it's a long game as
well as a short game yeah so I was
thinking okay that's that's got to be
the way so how much are you currently
making from your property business so
the property business currently is
probably a I'd say only making about
three at the moment 3K a month
um because I'm doing a refurb on one and
one's about to go through but it will I
would say within the next two or three
months it would be between four and five
k that's brilliant and again for like
four or five k a month
that's a full-time salary bro it's more
than I was making on my underneath yeah
so it's like okay I'm just getting
started I joined the academy in I think
April time
it's been not long and I'm thinking okay
I've done this I've gone from having
pretty much nothing to having four
properties in under a year yeah and
where will I be in five you know because
it's just a Snowball Effect isn't it
what advice would you give to somebody
that's you know a busy Flora roof or
whatever like a tradesperson like you
were that wants to get into property
that hasn't necessarily got the money
the net worth the knowledge but really
wants to start making money from
property
do you know what it it is a tough one
um
when I joined the Academy I paid towards
the academy that was pretty much all the
money that I had
because I saw that as that was my
investment I was thinking right if I I
could try and save and save and save and
then fumble around in the dark and think
right what am I going to do next but
then I thought if I spend this small
relatively small chunk of money on
educating myself
I'll then know how to and and since then
as well you know for the money that I've
spent I've got that back already because
I've even learned how to get around not
having to even use my money because of
the stuff that you've taught me yeah so
it was like so talk about how you do it
then so if you spent all your money on
education and you've got nothing what
other things that you do what are the
strategies in order to grow a portfolio
with no money well I mean you could sell
deals when you know what you're looking
for
um you can go out there and find them
there's there's plenty of people who've
got the money but they're either don't
know what they're doing or can't be
bothered or they're too busy because
they're earning loads of money but their
money is just sat in the bank if you
know what you're doing you can go out
and find a good property deal and sell
it on it's just quick cash yeah so what
what are some of the things that you've
done then what because you've been very
creative with joint ventures and
controlling properties what are some of
the strategies that you've done in order
to grow your portfolio for me you have
rent to rent a big one as well because
it takes a relatively small chunk of
money so by any putting down a I mean
sometimes you can get away with not even
using your own money or hardly any you
can finance things in that but for a few
grand you can get set up and get that
return straight away can't you so are
you for five grand roughly you know you
can get five to a thousand pounds a
month talk to me about your first rent
to rent
uh it's a good one it's a good one
um it's
it's in Reading
um I get a lot of um relocators quite a
few people from um
from from China Hong Kong they're coming
over it's just absolutely cleaning up
because it's quite close to London
um so it's 20 minutes on the train
they're coming over and they check
they're generally staying for like a
month two three months sometimes so I'll
get payment uh usually through Airbnb or
something like that
um and they'll literally just be in
there I'll do the clean but when they're
in there for a long time they don't
really want to want to be bothered so
it's just a total passive how's the
business model work so talk to me about
who's who's who's who's doing what
um at the moment generally because I've
only got a few I've got loads I've not
tried to
um sort of automate it as much yeah
because I I wanted to learn as well I
wanted to know exactly how to I'm doing
it I'm thinking for someone watching
this it doesn't even know when to rent
is uh okay so doing about doing a rent
to rent is um
uh basically it's called a corporate let
you go to a landlord
um and you rent that through a company
your company
um once you've got that you can then
boost the the income from that property
by renting it out on a nightly basis
instead of over a weekly or month so
your first one's in reading so how much
rent do you pay do you pay the landlord
uh that one's about 800 pounds a month
and it costs like 12 pounds to set a
company up yeah so you set up a property
company you agree to rent a property in
reading for 800 pounds a month yeah and
then what uh I charge roughly 90 to 100
pounds a night for people to stay there
so and sometimes a bit more during
festival and things like that as well
can go up to 250 300 a night and what's
your kind of occupancy rate generally uh
mine's probably about 90 to 100 wow so
weddings are banging area yeah it's a
good area yeah yeah and how much profit
do you make off that first winter event
that you got that one probably about
1200 a month that's incredible isn't it
yeah I mean you do that twice and you've
replaced the average salary it's crazy
yeah
yeah crazy
but and people weren't really really
hard for that sort of money as well
don't they yeah so I think you know it
is it's not it's never easy you know
nothing's easy if it's worth doing it's
not easy and some of the challenges that
you face by setting these things up yeah
you can you can be faced with certain
things oh you've got to fix that or
you're good but you learn and if you get
the proper training
you don't have to you know face some of
those problems on your own either or you
can avoid them before they happen are
all your intervents in Reading yes
are you going to get more in Reading
probably would yeah for now but I'm also
looking up north as well because that
the rent is the rent's a little bit
lower for what they can get but you can
still rent it out for the same if not
more there's quite a few Academy members
that I know that rent their places out
for 150 maybe more a night you know it's
interesting isn't it I saw it I saw an
academy member Post in Liverpool their
Airbnb calendar and they're charging
like 150 quid a night yeah and they're
paying like 800 quid
for like a really beautiful apartment
yes a no-brainer Birmingham as well I
think it's quite a good place why do you
think the landlords wouldn't just do it
themselves why are they passing
properties to companies like us well I
mean there's an element of laziness
maybe they might be they might have been
accidental landlords where they've just
got a property they don't really know
what to do with it they just want
someone to take it off their hands for
two three five years or whatever it is
um they might not know they might not
have the training I speak to a lot of
people and they and I say oh I'm doing
it like this and they're like oh really
I didn't even know about that you know
yeah people I think people are starting
to get to know Airbnb a little bit but
they still don't really quite understand
how how straightforward it can be if you
get the right and I guess as well you've
got the booking process payment process
having the stripe account yeah yeah
channel manager so many people off they
don't understand because it is a
business yeah it is and it's got to be
run that way it's got to be run
efficiently but yeah I suppose a lot of
landlords are just like I want to put
someone there and they'll pay me x
amount a month and it's maybe a bit of
laziness maybe they just want a
guaranteed rent don't they yeah exactly
yeah so what are you doing with the 20
grand that you won on the eviction uh so
we've got a brr in the Northeast
um we're purchasing it for a very good
value
um 70 000 I think it is wow and we're
doing that up that down south would have
been easily 450 to 500 000 so yeah like
oh okay so whereabouts is it it's in
Hartlepool yeah cheaper very cheap area
it is it is and uh I drove up there and
it is a funny area but I drove up there
and it's quite it seemed a little bit
dead because I was trying to do my due
diligence up there but once I got
chatting to some of the locals I
actually found out the demand for HMO up
there is huge oh wow because they can't
always afford or that you know they
can't can't set themselves up with a
full property yeah I quite often a lot
of them and housing associations and
there's a lot of opportunities you know
so you're buying it for 70 grand and
then what's the refurb so the refurb's
80. I I can't cover all that myself in
my winnings but I've now got skin in the
game so I'm going to be chucking my
winning and that's what you said
actually you said that when you was like
he said that you had potential joint
venture Partners but they wanted you to
put a bit of skin in the game yeah and I
think you know at the end of the day
I've I've paid to invest in my education
you know I've obviously went on the
eviction I've put myself out there
um but I think it is important that they
not only see that I've invested in
myself but I'm investing in it with them
yeah so how much are they putting in the
rest so it's going to be all cash yeah
okay wow so you're putting 20 grand in
they're putting about 130 Grand in yeah
so in total 150 and what's the end value
we hope it minimum 200 hopefully 220. so
you're then going to refinance it put
all that money out give the investor his
money back and then rent it out yeah and
is that 50 50. yeah six bed six
um ensuite HMO wow that should generate
about two and a half Grand a month
that's incredible isn't it that was a
good 20 grand well spent then yeah so
you didn't spend it on going on holiday
no that was already painful when I I had
a holiday book didn't I during the
eviction because when you won the
eviction you went straight off where did
you go yeah it was Turkey yeah my family
were already out there yeah I've been
out there about eight so yeah that has
already bought and paid for what what
did you learn in the eviction because
it's a very intense month it's a really
intense month it's like
in um I think the the months of April
onwards I did a course each month yeah I
did the week course each month yeah
but when I went on the eviction it was
like the crash course it was all of the
courses rolled into one boots on the
ground get it done and
for me I'm quite a practical learner so
sitting there and listening has you know
it's really inspiring listening to you
and and getting taught what you're what
you're saying but when I actually
implemented what you taught me and I had
to I was forced into a corner and I had
no way out I had to do it if I wanted
any chance of winning I had to get on
and do it that was the best experience
for me what why did you get so emotional
in the boardroom yeah
well I hadn't slept one wink that night
before it that didn't help I was like
all night just thinking what's gonna
happen tomorrow what's going to happen
tomorrow
um but for me
the whole reason I'm doing this is
because of the area that we live you
know and
my family my kids aren't getting any
younger any quicker so I want to try and
get them out of that area I want to try
and move somewhere that's that's nice
and away from violence and nastiness so
for me I'm I'm on a bit of a timer now I
just want to get stuff done and I'm
hoping in the next year or two you know
I'll be out of there yeah somewhere
better for them maybe somewhere Hartley
Paul no
so what's the next sort of what's the
what's 2023 gonna look like for you then
I can't wait
um so the brr that we've got I want that
moving real quick we've got build team
ready and in place
as soon as I'm obviously you've got to
wait a certain amount of time to be able
to to refinance for money laundering but
um I'm hoping to try and do at least
another two or three bras next year yeah
so man I was 36 I didn't have anything
I'm 37 and I'm looking at I've already
got four and I'm I'm looking to buy you
know two or three monies yeah it's crazy
you think that's impossible you think
you're gonna have to spend your life
saving up just to buy one property you
know especially if you're on an income
that's just about covering you know your
living costs you know trying to save and
then that money's going down in the bank
basically as you're saving it because
it's becoming worthless it just feels
like a mountain that you've got to climb
but it's not it's really not and yeah by
the end of next year if you wanted to
you could retire yeah
yeah I don't think I want to I think
I'll drive my wife crazy but yeah you
could you could I'm not quite as quick
as you you were there a bit quicker than
me well no it took me four years to
become financially independent yeah
um but with your training you know
there's no reason you can't be within a
year or two
have you made a lot of friends so many
yeah I'm quite a private person and even
going on the eviction
it was a bit out of my character but I
was like no come on let's go one of your
big things get comfortable feeling
uncomfortable yeah I was like no I'm
gonna do it and but for me I had
probably a handful of friends you know
before I started the eviction or started
the Academy I would I didn't really I
don't really I'm not a massive
socializer or anything like that but
having started on the academy the number
I can't keep up with a number of friends
that I've made you know someone will
contact me one day I'm like I haven't
spoke to ages and it's just loads and
loads of decent people and we're all
like-minded as well which is nice
everyone's really supportive you know
everyone wants to push everyone up yeah
and and it's a really nice yeah
atmosphere to be where do you find or
how did you find that BR deal how do you
get these types of banging deals that
was through another Academy member oh
wow yeah
um Lewis who's also been on what is
Wednesday yeah yeah
um he found it um I've been watching him
for a while and I just totally trust
people that are in the academy as well
because again they've invested in
themselves you know and I think once you
do that you deserve a bit of trust and
um yeah I did my due diligence and it's
yeah it's going to be banging but and
another thing is from the eviction
um
pretty much everybody that was on the
eviction
almost is now financially free yeah
isn't that incredible right it's proven
to put in there yeah I mean what kind of
success right is that that's just
Madness and same with the academy the
people that go through the 12 months on
the academy like the success rates you
see it every week
it's it's just crazy I know you go on
the Monday night Mastermind and it's
like financially free financially free
financially free financially free just
do their first deal just enough that
everyone's winning no it is crazy
sometimes you go in the crash course
even and I'm thinking oh it sounds all a
bit too good to be true but it's really
not because the proof is in the pudding
all these people are becoming
financially free yeah you know you're
waking people up what was it that made
you join the academy and justify wiping
your bank clean on a big investment in
yourself how do you justify that
the way I saw it was I could keep saving
and struggle to keep saving to try and
buy something else or I can invest in
myself
and I'll be able to move quicker because
it's another big thing we say in the
academy isn't it you know you can move
fast on your own yeah or you can move
far together yeah and I just felt like
even if you took your courses away you
know the the amount of people that you
get to mingle with it and that can help
each other that in itself yeah is worth
it the people yeah basically
um
yeah I was a bit I was in a bit of
trouble when I paid for that I didn't
even speak to my wife but but I just
went boring what did she what did she
say she was uh all right okay you didn't
want to talk to me about that then I was
like ah it's not right no no I just got
to do it you know and I did the same
with the eviction I didn't speak to
about that I just couldn't apply yeah
but interesting sometimes you just gotta
go for everything just say yes and
figure out the consequences exactly
which is a big thing it's my own
property you know a lot of people
overthink things sometimes you've taught
me that as well you know it's like I'm
worrying about your logo or you know
have I got this simply just get on and
do it yeah just do it how do you think
you've grown as a person over the last
sort of six months crazy mate yeah
mental like I just approach everything
differently you know
um I've definitely become more confident
um more comfortable in my own skin and
oh yeah loads of ways loads of ways what
will be your advice to people watching
this that want to sort of follow in your
footsteps and become successful in
property pay a pound yeah right get
yourself down there to a crash course
yeah yeah yes that's the way forward and
I think you you'd have to be an idiot if
you sat in a crowd at one of your crash
courses and think oh I don't think what
you're saying is true because nothing
that you say is it it totally makes
sense you know yeah and then once once
you go down there if you don't want to
invest in the academy then I suppose
life's short isn't it and if you don't
think right well what if you could walk
away from that crash course and think
no I'm not going to spend that you'd
probably spend the rest of your life it
cost you more because you'd spend the
rest of your life wondering what if I
had to pay for that that's true yeah
well mate I'm super pleased with what
you've done man and it's been great
working with you and obviously we've got
a lot more to go
um but it's gonna be amazing if you kept
in touch with any of the guys from the
eviction yeah yeah we've got WhatsApp
chats and um yeah we've been speaking
um in fact one of them today was even
telling me she's looking at doing a JV
um in Milo she's having a look at places
um so again it's just keeping in touch
with all these people that she's out
actively looking for deals all the time
you know Adriana as well she's up north
and she's even finding deals in reading
and she lives up north yeah staying in
contact with people is did you enjoy
watching the eviction
yeah I did I was a little nervous
because uh not a big fan of cameras but
it was edited really well I really
enjoyed it it should have been on the
Telly uh you know YouTube it feels like
it should just be everywhere yeah get it
on Netflix well you did great so
congratulations on the big win there as
well thank you very much it was smash
2023 brother thank you bro
[Music]